I have some video and audio for you
today that is truly the height of
absurdity when you talk about unelected
people in positions of huge power merely
because they are related to someone of
course our minds immediately should go
when I say that to Ivanka Trump and her
husband Jared Kushner Donald Trump's
son-in-law Jared Kushner was interviewed
by Time magazine earlier this week and
he was asked is it possible possible
that the November election could be
postponed because of coronavirus now
before I play the audio for you the
question is fraught the question is
fraught because it's not really up to
the Trump administration you'd have to
move heaven and earth to do it but you
could ask 50 states individually to
postpone their elections and there's a
question as to whether all states would
even be able to do it but even if you
managed to do that you could really only
delay the November election a few weeks
because in December the electors have to
certify that election unless you can
actually get what would likely need to
be a constitutional change or you know
maybe a Supreme Court decision it would
be insanely difficult to actually
postpone the November election it's also
a fraught question because Jared Kushner
should have no involvement their opinion
about this at all he's just Trump's
son-in-law he's been made an advisor
which is horrifying
but okay Jared Kushner is asked about
this now what I want to think about here
is whether this has been blown out of
proportion because there have been a lot
of apoplectic headlines saying Jared
Kushner is laying the groundwork to
postpone the presidential election are
trying to postpone the presidential
election I don't know that that's the
case necessarily looking at the clip
let's take a look at it there any
scenario including a second outbreak in
the fall where the elections need passed
November 3rd that's too far in the
future to tell nothing that I'm aware of
now but again our focus right now is
just on getting the elections will
happen on November 3rd it's not my
decision to make so I'm not sure I can
commit one way or the other but right
now that's the plan and
again hopefully by the time we get to
you know September October November
we've done enough work with testing and
with and with all the different things
we're trying to do so Jarrod says the
plan is for November third I can't
commit to it but it's not his position
to commit he has no power in when the
election is held even Trump essentially
has no power and when the election is
held so I actually do believe this was a
little bit blown out of proportion
there's another idea which is okay Jared
can't do anything about it but that's
why Jared said it it's a trial balloon
to gauge reaction to it if people go
absolutely crazy in the end jared has no
say or involvement in this so it's no
big deal on the other hand if Jared
Kushner were to say something and the
reaction to it is positive or not that
negative then this could be actually
sort of a trial balloon I just don't buy
it I think what happened here is that
Jared Kushner's wording is very clumsy
and what we're mostly reacting to is the
fact that Jared Kushner shouldn't be
involved at all in anything that's going
on he shouldn't be answering questions
about when the election is going to be
held he should be barred by nepotism
laws from even being involved with this
administration now don't get me wrong
Donald Trump may well be thinking of
trying to move the election he may end
up trying to move the election
I just don't think Jared Kushner's
comments or The Smoking Gun and I also
don't believe Trump would succeed in
doing it now in any case this blew up
and Jared Kushner ended up having to put
out a comment clarifying what he said
and he said quote I have not been
involved in nor am i aware of any
discussions about trying to change the
date of the presidential election so for
me the story is not Jared Kushner is
floating moving the election to me the
story is why are people talking to Jared
Kushner why is Jared Kushner involved in
things he knows nothing about Jared
Kushner has no authority Trump doesn't
even have the legal authority to move
the election are they trying to are they
likely the Trump administration are they
likely to try to do everything they can
to maintain power of course voter
suppression disinformation propaganda
lying about their hand
of coronavirus lying about the state of
the economy lying about Joe Biden
they're going to do what we would
colloquially call trying to rig the
election in their favor but it's not
going to be Jared Kushner changing
election day now what can we do number
one don't fall for the propaganda number
to push states to adopt vote-by-mail
number three get people registered
number four obviously make sure that you
vote one last thing on postponing the
election which i think is important that
and it should reduce the hysteria a
little bit if the election is postponed
imagine they succeed right I don't see
the path to it but imagine they succeed
and there's no new President to
inaugurate in January of 2021 I'm just
thinking out loud here the Speaker of
the House becomes the president now
right now that's Nancy Pelosi democratic
congresswoman Nancy Pelosi
I believe Trump will do anything that he
can to prevent Nancy Pelosi from
becoming president of the United States
now if you really want to get in the
weeds you could have a situation where
there's no election in November it
imagine I don't think it's good but
imagine there's no election in November
and because the election is postponed
you don't even have enough Congress
people to have them in DC with a quorum
to make Nancy Pelosi the president in
that case the next person in line
becomes the the next person in line to
be President would be the Senate
President Pro temp right now that's
Chuck Grassley this obviously gets very
dicey and that Republicans would likely
in that scenario try to prevent it from
going to Nancy Pelosi skip over her and
go to Grassley I'm merely going through
the motions here I don't believe this
would happen but there is a scenario
where the outcome of trumps postponing
of the election makes Nancy Pelosi the
president until an election is held
there's no way Trump is going to take
any action that would make that likely
one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman